# How Many Countries are There?
How many countries are there?
Easy: just grab a map and start counting,
yes?
No.
Not all maps are created equal -- borders
will differ depending on who you got the map
from.
So if individuals disagree, then surely a
committee will save the day.
Go to the United Nations, find the room where
countries sit -- each with a little name tag
-- start counting and get an answer.
Now of course, countries come and countries
go, but at the time this video was made the
answer is 193.
Fastest video ever, right?
Except: you know this isn't over.
The United Nations list is less a complete
class roster than a club membership that doesn't
include everyone.
Take, Vatican City who is a country but is
too cool for school when it comes to being
a member of the United Nations.
And while Vatican City's exact situation is…
complicated he's straightforward compared
to other non-United Nations countries… or
places -- the terminology is going to have
a be a bit, unclear here.
Take Kosovo, who want's to join the UN club,
but membership requires none of these five
countries to reject you.
And while the United States, The United Kingdom
and France think Kosovo is a country, Russia
and China think she's just a rebellious part
of Serbia and so veto her membership.
As for everyone else, just over half recognize
Kosovo as independent and Kosovo, adorably,
has a website where she thanks each one in
their own language.
But Kosovo, is not there only other… place
that wants to be considered a real country.
There's Transnistria, Nagorno-Karabakh Republic,
Abkhazia, and South Ossetia.
Which might, or might not, be part of Moldova,
Azerbaijan or Georgia depending on who you
ask.
Two of these… countries, no UN members recognize
as countries, and other two have only five
supporters.
Though all four of these... places recognize
each other as countries.
There's also The Sahrawi Arab Democratic Republic
and Northern Cyprus each with their own supporters.
At this point you might be thinking 'OK, srsly,
what's the deal?
I don't care who these guys think are countries,
are these places countries or not?'
If I fly to one for a Holliday, will it *look*
like a country when I get there?
The answer is, 'maybe'.
These... countries are all autonomous, to
some extent, with governments that issue passports
though these may be of rather limited use
and depending on which ones you're visiting
they may have more or less control of the
territory they claim as theirs.
You won't always find a clear border.
What makes many of these places... fuzzy is
they're *usually* born of conflict in the
recent-ish past.
That answer is probably less helpful than
you want so think of it like this: while The
United States is clearly a country now, in
1776, not so much.
Then she was just an idea in minds of rebel
scum.
She wasn't recognized as a country instantly
and without diplomatic effort to change that
Young America would never have made it on
her own.
Much like what happened a century later when
she got her own rebel who, unlike elder sister,
failed in the diplomacy department so… yeah.
And so it goes today with many of the maybe
countries in the world.
Maybe they're future United States and maybe
they're future Confederacies -- but in the
moment it's hard to say -- because these things
can take decades to settle.
By the way, these maybe-countries are super
awkward for countries to deal with.
While your tiny island nation might not want
to get involved in the affairs of distant
lands you still have to decide to send a diplomat,
or not -- meaning even inaction forces you
to pick a side in *every territorial skirmish
in the world*.
A notably awkward case being: Taiwan… errr,
sorry, Chinese Taipei which is *totally* part
of China and no one would ever think otherwise…
Is China gone?
OK: by any reasonable definition, Taiwan is
a separate country and has been for years,
but China won't let go and insists you call
her Chinese Taipei and don't forget who makes
all your clothing and utensils and TVs and
phones and computers and everything.
So almost all countries -- including the mighty
United States -- plays along even though they
unofficially acknowledge Taiwan's independence
and do things that wouldn't make any senses
otherwise -- like sending aircraft carriers
to protect one part of China from another
part of China.
Thus the innocent question 'how many countries?'
has led us straight to a big 'World War III:
Press Here to Start' button which is getting
depressing so lets move on to...
Ohhhh, right.
::sigh::
No more politics: on to higher ideas: The
Olympics.
Surely from their perch among the gods they
have a disinterested view of the countries
below.
"How many are there, Olympics?"
Two hundred and four?
Huh.
So Olympics is a bit… special.
She defines Puerto Rico as a 'country' even
though it's unambiguously part of the United
States as well as Bermuda and Aruba which
are connected to the UK and The Netherlands
along with a bunch of other places that are
happy to play in her Olympic Games as Nations
but make no claims to independence.
Presumably, Olympics includes these to bump
up the number so she can say 'more than 200
countries compete!'
Though even her inflated list doesn't include
Vatican City -- because, given his demographics,
divine intervention would be required to take
home a gold.
And Vatican City brings us right back to the
core of the difficulty with this question:
a consistent definition of 'country' is impossible
because your checklist needs to both include
Vatican City the least country-like country
that's still a country -- and that also exclude
the Anti-Vatican City: Hong Kong: -- the most
country-like country that isn't.
Also don't forget from previous episodes the
seemingly endless territories which look and
act like independent countries, but just sort
of aren't.
And this isn't even brining up the various
Nutters who plant a flag on an Island, or
an oil rig, start printing currency on their
fancy inkjet and declare Deludtopia a new
nation.
So with no checklist to follow where does
that leave us?
The best answer to the question 'how many
countries' for the forceable future is probably
to say 'around 200' and leave it at that.
An answer with more significant figures implies
more agreement than there really is -- because
ultimately, what makes a country a country
is if other countries think that country is
a country.